ich bin geschädigte der thomas cook
pleite sind pauschalreisen
pauschalreisen werden ja eigentlich über
den reisesicherungsschein abgesichert
ich habe über 2000 euro bezahlt also
eine reise voll eine reise an gezahlten
wir sehen wollten sehen was ich wollte
zweimal die türkei fahren zweimal die
türkei fliegen und einmalig drei vier
tage vor der insolvenz erwischt und
jetzt nochmals für den sommerurlaub
ich habe noch keinen cent noch keinen
einzigen cent bekommen wie stehen sie
dazu
ich kann ihre ungeduld absolut verstehen
ich bitte aber so ein bisschen um
verständnis dafür
ich will einmal die dimension aufzeigen
wir haben circa 200.000 geschädigte die
von thomas cook pleite betroffen sind
und wir als bundesregierung uns war es
wichtig dass wir gesagt haben wir
verweisen die einzelnen geschädigten
nicht auf den individual- klageweg
sondern wir sagen ihr tretet uns die
ansprüche ab und dafür werden wird dann
die differenz zwischen dem was an
gezahlt und etwas zurückgegeben wurde
von vom insolvenzverwalter bzw von der
versicherung die differenz wird dann
übernommen aber 200.000 geschädigte das
muss alles genau kontrolliert werden
denn ich muss ja jede einzelne jeden
einzelnen vorgang auch prüfen lassen
denn ich gebe ja hier steuergeld aus
deswegen muss genau geprüft werden sind
die voraussetzungen erfüllt ich muss
genau prüfen sind die anhand frischer
abgetreten worden
und dafür werden gerade momentan die
entsprechenden voraussetzungen
geschaffen dass wir nämlich so ein
portal anbieten
dass das dann abwägen kann deswegen
bitte ich sie noch um etwas geduld sie
können sich ausrechnet 200.000 die
durchschnitts summe ist so bei 800 das
ist richtig viel geld wenn man seinen
nächsten sommerurlaub planen will ich
weiß das und bei ihnen sind 3000 euro
aber wenn sie noch ein bisschen geduld
haben ich würde mal sagen so in diesem
quartal und wir sind ja schon mitte
februar
da wollen wir eigentlich anfangen dass
es dann auch in die umsetzungsphase geht
aber wir haben diese entscheidung ende
des jahres getroffen
ich musste auch als in der regierung war
das rennen
tief schnell klar aber in anderen
fraktionen im deutschen bundestag war
das nicht so klar dass wir hier ein
treten deswegen musste das durch den
haushaltsausschuss das sind alles solche
weil ich habe ja nicht im
justizministerium säcke mit geld stehen
aus denen ich dann eben diese aussage
dass es lange dauert ist das eine wir
schauen ja auch genau hin weil es eben
steuergeld ist genommen sagen frau
lambrecht und trotzdem hebt sie ihn jan
bauer erst mal nichts das geld ist
einfach noch nicht zurück können sie
denn sagen das geld kommt es dauert halt
einfach noch in das ist oder eine
hundertprozentige zusage die haben sie
die haben wir auch öffentlich erklärt
dass ich dafür drei tagen verschiedene
verschiedene rechtsanwälte sagen das ist
nur eine absichtserklärung ich habe
definitiv noch keine zusage der
bundesregierung wenn sie hier und heute
mir sagen es kommt in diesem quartal
aber das war eindeutig glaube ich gerade
jetzt wirklich jeder von diesen 200.000
in diesem quartal das kann ich nicht zu
sagen denn wie gesagt 200 vorgänge
müssen geprüft werden aber es ist eine
definitive zusage
das geld wird kommen wir beginnen in
diesem quartal aber da kann es bei dem
einen oder der anderen ja auch durchaus
noch rückfragen geben und sich etwas
verzögern
aber es ist keine absichtserklärung
sondern eine ganz feste zusage wir haben
sogar die mittel mittlerweile aus dem
haushaltsausschuss bewilligt deswegen da
die voraussetzungen auf der seite sind
da aber sowas muss eben auch umgesetzt
werden